you
[Music]
it's an honour and to honor to have Mike
Jordan with us today
mike is a professor in the Department of
EECS and statistics at UC Berkeley and
he's been obviously as many of you know
an energetic leader I'd say at the
intersection of statistics and the
visions put forth by the founders of the
areas of AI and cybernetics in terms of
possibilities for computational
intelligence he's worked in both theory
and in practical applications some of
the practical work includes his efforts
in in genetics and signal processing
information retrieval we all know about
some of the work there in natural
language on a technical side he's made
contributions significant contributions
in public graphical models Bayesian
nonparametric analyses special methods
kernel machines and applications to
distributed computing systems among
other areas sticking the problem for
models like I am I have to say that some
I first met Mike out started thinking
that the witness was very salient memory
we both didn't have gray hair at the
time that's for sure might read great a
couple months ago I don't know about you
but it was in Corvallis there was a
Bayesian published graphical model
summer school in Corvallis that that
boosts abramson
I taught break like it was a morning
break and like Michael was that the most
engaged student in the room be so say he
walked up muttering this stuff is
incredible this stuff is incredible I
already said that these publish the
graphical models are incredible and I
guess it was one of your early exposures
but you were just like really lucky just
to be just like we're like dry kindling
ready to be lit on fire I can just at
that moment it was a just to see that
that phase and the comment you once
mentioned to me I don't maybe tell the
group this sexual story you said that
you were doing X and I think it was
maybe it was stat somewhere and you had
this chance to go hang out with Don
Norman and rub man and Dave Romo heart
and the way you the picture you paint it
I think was over over dinner one night
is
you were like on this like this
out-of-control kayak going near a
waterfall you jumped and you grabbed a
branch you said he said you just grabbed
a branch this stop what you were doing
and going a new direction and that's
exactly how you put it so you maybe you
could tell us more about my memory there
but anyway but it's really if I was
happy here I didn't finish your whole
bio here but let me just say that
Michael has received many well-deserved
recognition you commute about them and
the bio online and today Mike's talking
about gradient based optimization
accelerated non-convex and stochastic
take it away Thanks all right maybe the
most idiosyncratic introduction I've
ever had I wish I could just keep on
going it was very entertaining okay so
I'm just gonna dive in I'm a technical
research or academic and I just kind of
work on the next wave of things and all
of this buzz in height a little bit
problematic here is it's hard to avoid
but I did but a little cottage in my
garden and there's no internet down
there so I mostly could avoid it but I
was recently in Denali Betty ragazze in
China and I'm in the men's room and the
people behind you're talking about deep
learning in the men's room and I finally
this week wrote AB last week I wrote a
blog thing kind of put a few thoughts
out there just lay them down and
apparently I do know I'm not on social
media at all but apparently it's what
you call viral so it was read a lot so I
will not just jump into my kind of most
my interests I'm gonna say a little bit
about this broader picture and I do you
know probably even more about a I'm not
an AI research I'm a statistician so so
many of you with apologies will know
more than me but I do think that this
word is unfortunate I think it's a great
aspiration I think at least why I think
America our students it was you know the
aspiration that you know we had
computers but can they be made to seem
intelligent in some way and I think it's
still an interesting aspiration someone
turn down the gain a little
here I'm getting a feedback am I only
hearing it to say it was resonating high
frequencies yeah so we don't have it yet
we don't have it we don't know what
intelligence is I think yeah and all
these neural nets are things are just
taking a data mimicking intelligent and
I don't know if we're gonna have it
anytime soon we don't need it really for
most things that you know there's also
many cool things we can do without
trying to figure out what it is and also
a lot of the people who work on you know
it use the AI buzzword these days are
interested in autonomous systems because
then it's really you know it's it's
really intelligent cuz no one's telling
what to do and I think that's fine but
it's somewhat misguided to really all of
our telogen should be networked together
and it should be you know decisions
should be made not independently they
should be made products of other
decisions and so on so I think that AI
is used too much as a just a wild card
you throw it in whatever you need to and
I don't also watch television but I
gather that Mark Zuckerberg but in front
of Congress recently and I gather that
whenever he was asking any kind of a
challenging question he'd say well AI
will handle that I don't like I have a
16 x in his talk you know so there's a
little hubris there about computer
science say we just did you resolve it
and also let's break things and then
later fix them and all that but when you
use AI is an intellectual wild card
that's just not responsible and I just
don't think that we should in a
community should be supporting that kind
of irresponsible dog so I wish we
weren't saying AI that's fine as an
aspiration but already machine learning
kind of bothered me because we had this
this one 300 years called statistics
which was the same stuff that's so well
I lost all those battles
laurens let me skip over that slide so
in this blog I said let's don't use AI
is for everything let's make some
distinctions okay and there's some
historical ones that are still relevant
and then there's there's ones that have
been do with what problems we should be
solving and it's big so let's call it
human imitative AI that's kind of where
it was back in the origins and it's like
Orion had in mind and it's a great
aspiration to think about how do we get
this thing that we know is intelligence
inside of a sort of computer but really
then the next you know a few decades
came forward and I don't think very much
progress is made on that we don't really
have anything like intelligence yet but
we did have lots of pattern recognition
stuff and lots of you know information
retrieval stuff and you know and
algorithms all kinds and I think it's
mostly IA it's mostly augment our
intelligence you know so search engines
augment our telogen s--
translation systems do you know and so
and so forth and interacting with humans
and making not replacing human
intelligence but making it somehow more
interesting and more deep that's what's
happened but also i think what's
happened is this thing that's often
called Internet of Things by you know
that's computer science that's just kind
of a limited version of it no the real
bigger version it's the one I think most
of us are kind of used to is that all
around us there's a network of
intelligence that were the system
behaves intelligently it gives us
options for transportation it gives us
options for medical care gives us
options for financial services commerce
and so on and we want that overall
system to behave intellij and to do that
you don't need the individual nodes to
be intelligent agents at all you want
the overall system behave intelligent in
the context of human aspirations and
goals okay so if we think about that
this focus on vision and speech and you
know NLP and robotics is this place
because though you don't need those for
these grander goals and you know those
are hard problems they're not solved at
all to this day and focusing only of
them makes you not focus on many of the
other problems that are really really
important so I just wrote down some ones
I've been interested in working on I
mean some of them are classical AI
aspirate
but many of they're not so I'm gonna
talk a little bit about multiple
decision-making if you're in the class
in the AI world you think about an age
at making a decision and then maybe you
think about sequels of decisions
that's the reinforcement party but the
real-world problem is you make a hundred
thousand decision simultaneously for the
current medical city owner around the
world or for the transportation network
or whatever and how do you control
errors across those so you can't trick
each decision independently and think of
about as intellectual agents also I'm
really certain systems that don't just
have data flowing around but use that
data flow to create markets and the
creat value and making people be able to
enter into markets and get get things
out of it other than just having a
platform that they go to uncertainty to
this day so we're not talked about very
well about by the machine learning
people they don't seem to care about it
because they just think there's enough
data there's no uncertainty and that's
just wrong they didn't think about
domains were like search or or commerce
where if you give the wrong answers no
one dies or no one's hurt or no it's
really really inconvenient but we're
trying to roll this out in worlds where
people do die get hurt inconvenienced
then uncertainty matters critically you
tell me some machine learning algorithm
analyze might not genome and my my
current physiological state and says I
need to have a heart operation I'm gonna
say how sure you about that should we
get some more data what if this happened
all the other kind of things around
these systems cloud edge interactions if
you're gonna really build something like
self-driving car you need to be able to
have local intelligence it's fast and
you need to go up to the cloud forget
more computation you need to communicate
you need to solve the problem you know I
have nothing to do with human
intelligence but are critical and
moreover this overall system will have
different kinds of knowledge in
different cars they don't have to get
transmitted and made made a chord you
know those are the interesting
challenges anyway I could go on
provenance is one that you know the
database people talk a lot about but I
think this is really really critical
you're gonna measure date at one place
and one time you know in one situation
and it needs to be used in another place
time and situation and you've got to
record some information it makes it
possible to move it from one place and
have some reliability about doing that
so you know a lot of my email colleagues
just say well that's boring that's not
the exciting you know well no it's not
boring that's how I what like database
people did they changed the world by
building principles that you could build
reliable database
now the banking system to develop for
example so I've still get a lot of
feedback I don't know if that could be
turned down I don't know if you are
hearing it but I'm hearing those squeaky
stuff okay so let's talk to me about my
multiple decision so I'm gonna kind of
go something quickly through this
because they're both of my talk is some
other stuff but there's a statistical
field called statistics and it studies
things like what if I'm going to make
errors if I'm making mini mini decisions
not just one or a sequence of them and
here's kind of your classic a little
cartoon someone says jelly beans cause
acne let's do an a/b test so I'm gonna
take a hundred people put 50 and the
jelly beans category and 50 the no jelly
beans the six weeks later I look at
their skin and see if they develop acne
in one condition or the other and you
know high probability that didn't happen
and you say don't doesn't cause jelly
beans doesn't call acne but then someone
comes back and says well we got a
certain color causes it so now they do
all the experiments for all the
different colors and you know what
happens at some point by chance alone
the people already had a bad skin
condition get put in the treatment and
everybody else with control and it looks
like by chance alone that green and
jelly beans are like acting and then the
scientists getting all excited cuz it's
a surprising thing they publish it the
journals are happy to publish because
it's surprising the journalists picked
up on it and everybody's all excited
about this until it all dies down all
right it's a wash in this and yeah if
it's just journalism and so on and
health you know or how what you diet who
cares but if it's medicine and finance
and commerce and things that really
matter this really matters a whole lot
so you know you hope you know how many
of you all know about false discovery
rate I'm just a sort of time yeah
everybody here doing this is a mess well
that's a good sign so it's it's a you
know if you take a little two-by-two
table of your classification table zero
one zero one there's certain ratio in
that that's called the precision a
certain a certain another one it's
called recall another one's accuracy and
there's also another one's called FDR
it's just in that little table it's not
a brand new thing out
happens to be one that you've been
aggregated across multiple decisions and
get control over the overall error
fractions of errors in that in that so
Pitney control FDR well starting with
menu meaning hog board there was a line
of a search that's been doing that and
it is real important to know about but
it made strong assumptions it assumed
that you had independence and no logical
constraints and as time has gone on
boy I'm surprised okay I'll just try to
not use high frequencies in my voice
yeah that's his video feed answer again
I'll just I'll ignore it if you guys
will ignore it for a while okay that's a
good musicians fact these assumptions
and I just want this is a piece of
publicity I don't want to give this a
separate talk but we just written a
paper which i think is kind of a very
full version of this you could now have
hypotheses are related by a directed
acyclic graph so if this hypothesis is
true this must be there's a logical
constraint and so if you reject this
when you must reject this one that's
being allowed now more of it could be
done in an online matter that you can
start rejecting hypotheses are accepting
and over time and I can stop you at any
moment and your error fraction up to
that moment should be under control and
so there's a simple relevant simple
algorithm that does these kind of things
now why am i holding this
all right but I also want to focus on
another side of multiple decisions as
les discussed and it is about load
balancing and this is where economic
ideas I think are coming into play
so think about situations where we're
making a hundred thousand decisions like
in a transportation system or medical
system now if there's no scarcity of
resources this is you know not stupid
deal but in real world there's almost
always scarcity of resources so let's
think about a recommendation system you
know Amazon built one you come in and it
recommends maybe a movie to you and it
does that by looking all the features it
knows about you and and so on now later
this that day someone else comes on in
this system and a recommendation is made
to that person and those are
independently done right and suppose
it's suppose it skates that you
recommend the same movie to everybody
you know a hundred thousand people can
your site you know ninety nine thousand
got to a certain movie recommendation
that's fine there's no scarcity I can
stream the same bits to everybody right
what if I recommend the same book to
everybody well it's a little bit of a
moral problem if ninety nine thousand
people or it's gonna be a little bit of
a problem right well really not getting
the poor the problem of course the
problem is something more like this what
if I recommend the same restaurant to
sell every one so tonight in Redmond
ever you all go out and your app says
you know we recommend this restaurant
you know based on your profile and all
that my plus own statistics there's a
bigger chance that you know four hundred
people get recommend to the same
restaurant you all go there and there's
a line and no one's happy no one's
getting served how do you fix that well
if you're a you know computer science is
full of hubris you say you know
Zuckerberg type person you say we just
better algorithms AI you know yeah well
no that's not gonna really work we're
not gonna be able to know how to do that
loud balancing there's all kinds of
issues it would arise what if we figure
out the best path from here to the
airport and we recommend that to you but
and to you and to you right well
everybody will go down the same street
alright and again you might think
there's no big deal I mean fix that
those are small problems right but they
really aren't and so now think about I'm
building a financial service and I'm
gonna roll it out let's say in China to
500 million people and
because people got some money and I'm
gonna make a recommendations to them you
know this financial inserted buy that
stock right Mike wass on statistic
there's a good chance I'm going to
recommend a hundred thousand people to
buy certain stock I'm gonna destabilize
the market and I hope you can these
aren't cartoon so you can you can see
that this is really the core of the
problem okay so now how do you fix this
well you bring in economics you don't
just treat this as a platform that you
build and do machine learning on
all right you recognize that whenever
you've made data flow you can build on
top of that economic ideas all right
so think about the restaurant situation
what you really need is a two-way market
okay so you need that the people and the
restaurants have an app and the people
who are the customers have a different
amp right the people of restaurants say
tonight I have 50 seats open you know
there's a wedding on there but I got 50
seats open and I prefer people from out
of town and I Pro feed young people
whatever I have some policy right and so
now when I walk out of the movie in 7
p.m. my app says that restaurant knows
about you and it makes a 10 percent
discount for the next 10 minutes all
right I look at say uh huh great and I
accept and now the other app has filled
one of the seats in the restaurant
there's now 49 seats left and it keeps
going until it's full and then it's an
open market all the other restaurants
see that that you know favorite
restaurant is now full and it starts
making they start making their own
offers Oh big opportunity I like a 30%
discount and I'll fill my restaurant
tonight for the first time ever right so
now they just buy the connection of data
you're able to build a two-way market
all right and you're ready to solve the
load balancing problem it's just gone
okay plus you'll be able to make
connections between business and
consumer directly not between you as a
computer science platform and and
business or you and science platform and
the customer directly between them and
you've created a market now if you want
to take your 5 percent cut it you can
make money off of that that's all good
all right now here's another example so
I've involved in a company called United
masters I'm on their scientific advisory
board it's a fantastically interesting
company it's if the people really in the
music business but kind of on the on the
musician side so it's easier than ever
to make music people were making really
good music on the weekends not their
full-time job and uploaded in SoundCloud
and then the streaming services are
getting that musicans and people are
listening to it more than ever before
but no money is flowing no one's making
money off of that and that's a problem
because people don't can't have that as
a job and there's a big loss of you know
opportunity that a market would be able
to create so how do you fix that
well you create a market all right so
this particular company is doing that
the following way they partner with the
people who have the data flow and for
any given budding musician you know at
the top you know 100 that the record
companies have picked up on the next
hundred thousand or a million they take
each one them and and they collect all
the data of all the people who flew been
listening to them and then they reveal
that to them on a dashboard so all we
can see a map of the California and I
would see all the cities this week who's
been you know how many people been
listening to me
or of the whole US right and a lot of
these people they they have a big mr.
ship so if I learn for example that for
some reason and Orlando Florida there's
10,000 people been listening to me this
past week you know somebody liked them
and told their friends then I based on
the data I would go give a concert and I
could maybe make twenty five thousand
dollars and if I do that three times
during the year I have a salary and I
don't have to drive a taxi during the
week and make music on the weekends I
have a salary suddenly moreover there's
a connection now again between the the
merchant and the consumer the musician
now knows who listens to him or her and
they can make offers to them I'll play
your daughter's wedding for $10,000 or
you can come backstage and so on so I
now have a market and I can price things
and compete and have points and loyalty
programs and you name it and now people
can have jobs right and we don't have
musicians who have jobs mostly right now
I know a lot of musicians and there's
none of them have jobs except the top
100 like Beyonce that are getting
promoted at - so computer science could
be done to do that if you partner with
economics and data science data is the
thing that glues it all together okay I
think I'm gonna skip this other one
that's another kind of business about
economics
okay so I had a list of challenges there
and I picked a couple that I just want
to talk about that brought up some
themes and sums these are really things
that I'm currently interested in and
working on okay and so I don't have you
know results per se to talk about but
I'm quite convinced the results are
gonna come let me talk a little bit
about now turn to the core of what I
promise to talk about and so we're gonna
be linking statistics and computer
science so I am really an academic I
don't want to just do this in an ad hoc
way and you know create something that
kind of works but I wonder stand the
fundamental principles to grow in
particular certain lower bounds more and
more these days because that strips away
all the in essential stuff and lets you
focus on the essentials and I don't
think that machine learning has achieved
what people think it's achieved that it
blended statistics computer science in
some deep way I think that borrowed
ideas from here they're kind of put them
together willy-nilly but it doesn't
there's no foundational principles that
have emerged by bringing those two
together and we're missing those
foundational principles so in particular
data analysis problems have a time
budget so you need to be able to say
something like you know well I can
finance it's microseconds you know and a
searcher
you know internet it's milliseconds you
know in medicine maybe it's hours but it
was always time budget and the idea that
you control risk under a time budget is
just not familiar to either
statisticians or computer scientists at
a theoretical level okay so how do we
start to do that so I think many of us
who work in this more theoretical branch
the field think that optimization has
provided the best help with this
especially if you're thinking about
lower bounds and complexity results if
your science doesn't have Hardy any
lower bounds and mostly the ones that
you have are kind of meaningless that's
because the computer science model is
too strong
taurine complexity is just too strong
that try doing everything we need to do
not everything and we get more
meaningful balance so optimization 3
does exactly that so it's provided
algorithms and insights statistics also
has a lot of good lower balance I mean
you've heard of Kramer a lower bound but
there's a lot of others and they have
been very important for this older field
to progress and so taking in statistics
lower bounds and matching them with
optimization or balance is turning out
to be very productive
okay moreover you used to be I learned
opposition in the 80s and it was it was
taught as a finished field there was
simplex and gradient and conjugating was
just done there was software for all of
it it was just done all right and that's
turned out to be completely wrong all
the new problems that we're getting and
plus the kind of perspectives that arose
out of the Soviet Union with wait these
methods have really changed everything
all right so in fact those of us who
work on this focus on really simple
algorithms that can work in a computer
science scalable since so we restrict
ourselves to gradients no Hessians at
least for now that'll probably change we
do stochastics because it's cheaper and
our data is noisy anyway and then we
work on acceleration because the
geometry matters an acceleration allows
you to bring in geometry and it also
allows you to achieve some of the lower
bounds that I was referring to and then
how these things all interact in a
detailed way is what all of us were
working on and main knowledge a couple
of people in Russia one who I met this
morning it's worked a lot on these
things and she Jen sitting in the front
as a student at Berkeley who's expert on
I would be talking about some of his
work but many others this has been a
topic that I think is a you know the our
field of machine learning is very very
popular these days a lot of building
deep learning is everything and I have
nothing against deep learning it's great
but at the same time there's just been
just as much progress if not more on
this theoretical wing and it's less
aware but you know people here and other
places have been doing this ok so I
learned from Qi you know the bad local
minima which I thought were the core
problem when you went to non convex
problems are not so bad after all maybe
at least in wide class of problems so
there's a lot of front architectures
which in the last few years people have
proved to have no local Menem at all
they have a single global optimum and
then a ring of saddle points around that
and so it's really saddle points that
are the problem and if you think about a
saddle point there's sort of a lot of
directions where you're coming down but
then they go back up again and there's
only precious few directions that allow
you to get out all right now why is that
a problem well in two or three
dimensions it would be a problem but in
a hundred thousand dimensions it may be
it's very very hard to find that
direction leads you to get out and it
could take huge amount of time and in
fact when you train neural nets you see
the the error rate comes down real fast
and it flattens out and then you wait
for some indeterminate
time and then it comes down again you're
in the saddle point and you probably hit
a couple of saddle points right and so
we need if we're gonna really understand
anything about how long it's gonna take
to train these things and how you know
as things get larger and larger
we need something about the dimension
dependence okay so not as rate of
convergence the classical thing after
how many iterations you need to be with
an epsilon of the optimum but as a
function of dimension as well okay so
there's a saddle point and two or three
dimensions we're gonna be interested in
how do you escape it efficiently meaning
an efficient and computer science sense
and specifically getting the dimension
dependence kind of naively you might
think it'd be exponentially kind of to
search all combinations of directions
right so this has worked with Chi and
some others are wrong good Shaun Takata
was here in the city and Bernadette
Rapala who's at MSR is that correct yes
and in India okay so here's a little bit
of background that led to this
particular line of work that I want to
focus on in joint work with Jason Lee
and others we were able to show that
gradient is sent asymptotically we'll
never end up in a saddle point
if anyone's intuition but this has been
an open problem actually for gradient
flow which is the continuous version of
grading ascent it's the differential
equation in X is equal to minus the
gradient that's been known for about 100
years
based on most theory that asymptotic
avoids but that's asymptotics and it's
been but and it's been open for the
gradient the descritization great flow
so that sounds good but then there's a
negative result with again G Jana and
Simon do that that greatness that can
take exponential time to avoid saddle
points ok yeah so there's a class of
functions which aren't that weird where
it does take exponential time
so it's something of a surprise that she
and some others proved a theorem in 2015
that showed that if you add
stochasticity of a certain kind you you
go from exponential down to polynomial
right now that results still left us a
little bit short of the explanation of
why green ESN is so effective in
stochastic gradient so effective it's
just polynomial it could be you know a
high degree polynomial ok so the goal in
this line of work was to prove a
stronger through
okay so let's get started let's talk
about convex optimization F is convex
let's look at gradient descent there it
is go down the gradient and it's a fact
that you get convergence to a global
minimum under very very weak conditions
and moreover more importantly for this
talk the number of iterations to get
there is independent of dimension that's
less well and appreciated it's kind of
an amazing fact you can be in infinite
dimensions and the number of iterations
to get the optimum is the same as if
you're in finite dimensions so some
caveats there but that's basically true
now let's go on beyond greedy just
beyond convex problems let's go to the
non convex world that people like
Sebastian or helped us get into so here
we could have local Maxima we can have
saddle points and local minima so what
can we say about that world okay so
first of all just briefly this is that
list since probably gotten longer about
non convex problems that have only
improve ibly have a single global
optimum and they have saddle points is
that is the problem okay so an
interesting list it doesn't include
neural nets but it is codes lots of
other interesting important problems
okay so let's just set up the basic
theory the classical case for gradient
case and then move on to the non convex
case so for the classical convex case
one talked about a simple smoothness
assumption the gradient doesn't change
much the kind of the minimal assumption
you could make and then you attempted to
prove that an algorithm would converge
to a first order stationary point so
that would be a point where the gradient
equal to zero classical stationary point
from calculus and then we put a little
exelon ball around that so that we can
get a rate so you can do it for
different values of epsilon you can talk
about the rate at which you're
approaching the optimum that's why the
epsilon is there so it's called an
epsilon first or stationary point and
here is an example of a result due to
Nesterov which shows that the
convergence rate is one over epsilon
squared which is polynomial rate it says
if you want a really small epsilon the
number of iterations is gonna be more
it's gonna grow this is the initial
distance to the optimum and that doesn't
make that makes sense if you're far away
you got to get there let's go take that
Monde time and there's your Lipschitz
constant no dimension dependence that
that's the amazing thing about this
algorithm no dimension dependence okay
what about going beyond that so let's go
down to the non-convex case so
first-order stationary is no longer an
appropriate criterion because saddle
points are first-order stationary now we
don't want to hit saddle points so we
need to go beyond that let's define a
notion of second-order stationarity
where the gradient is the ends 0 or you
put a ball around that to get a rate and
the minimum eigen value is very go to 0
but again you let a little slop you let
it go slightly negative so you can get a
rate and this is a particular
parameterization of that amount of
negativity that row is a Lipschitz
constant out for the Hessian we need to
make a little smooth assumption also in
the Hesse because that the Hessian
changes wildly you're not going to be
able to converge out of a saddle point
ok so this is the original paper doing
this there's been some work since then
but this is kind of a minimal algorithm
a simple algorithm that it can be
analyzed theoretically so it's just
grading descent but from time to time
sporadically you add uniform noise from
a ball around your current iterate you
do that when the gradient is small but
you don't do it too frequently there's a
parameter T which says you only do it
once every T steps this can be removed
and that particular choice of uniform
ball is not essential but the basic idea
of having to have Stokoe stochasticity
is certainly necessary we saw the
exponential rate before and this is just
an example of an algorithm can be
analyzed relatively simply ok so here is
the here is the theorem from this work
by Chi GN at all and and it's so the
number of iterations on it all these
assumptions to find a second-order
stationary point now not first order it
looks exactly the same as the nesstra
result it's 1 over epsilon squared just
since the optimum Lipschitz constant the
only difference is that little twiddle
right there which is a standard
theoretician strip for hiding the
dimension dependence but we don't want
to hide that initiative it's the whole
point of this talk so we're being honest
about it and there it is
it's poly logarithmic in dimension so
it's not polynomial it's way better than
that it's logarithmic
totally okay that for is probably an
artifact of a particular proof technique
but it's probably logarithmic is the
truth but it is logarithmic okay so that
I think is perhaps one of the first ex
you know convincing reasons why you
should think stochastic gradient should
work well in high dimensions because
it's dimension dependence is so
favorable the proof technique here
basically involves in some sense some
differential geometry around a saddle
point there is a region the Hessian is
varying so there's a region where if
you're in that region you it's hard to
get out of it that the the flow due to
the negative eigenvalue doesn't hit you
fast enough and you're sort of stuck for
a long time all right so you need to
measure the width of this region and
this paper used a coupling technique
from probability theory it said I don't
know that width but I start to coupled
diffusions
there are with far apart and then very
are until you get a phase transitions
when they start to fly a fly apart from
each other that point you know the width
okay so you don't just have to do kind
of out replaces with a flat slab which
had been done in the previous work to
get the polynomial dependence and this
logarithm that comes out of that
argument okay
all right so with that is background
there's a cute few key ideas that have
been emerged in this that they're going
to be allowing us to look at some other
problems so first of all I haven't said
anything yet about acceleration again
there's some real experts in the room
and as they will tell you acceleration
is pretty important if you could be a
theoretician it adds momentum to the
problem
it allows you to achieve some of these
Oracle rates and we want to bring it
into contact with these other ideas so
how there's been an open problem if I'm
arriving at a saddle point is it
possible to kind of blaze past the
saddle point because of the momentum I
built up or its momentum not independent
it's sort of not helping me with saddle
points can we use other kinds of
stochastic models not just this one and
if we go to kind of fold stochastic
models we talked about talking about
diffusions and how the diffusions
interact with the kind of this convex
and non convex geometry so all kinds of
new problems when we start to look at
in my group we have gotten a lot of help
by thinking about these problems not in
discrete time but in continuous time and
so that's probably the big message of my
talk is that if you thought you could
avoid differential equations and you
went into computer science to avoid
differential equations I'm sorry to tell
you you're gonna have to learn about
differential equations right now why
well we're trying to develop fast
algorithms and atoms that we know how
fast they can be and what's like we have
to we want to analyze like what's the
fastest rate and so what does it mean to
have the speed of an algorithm if I'm
just hopping along some discrete points
what does it mean to hop faster all on
those discrete points well it means
you've invented the problem in a
continuum of time somehow all right all
right and if you get a bed the problem
in a continuum of time you have to start
talking to later differential equations
okay so this line of work has done that
and it's gone pretty far at this point
so I'll tell you a little bit about
variational Hamiltonian symplectic
perspectives and really Besson is now a
postdoc but he was a student with me and
Asia is still the student with me one
more year and they played a major major
role in developing this this work the in
particular the variational or
Hamiltonian framework and then Asia has
gone quite a bit further with Leona
respectives on all of this stuff and
then on this symplectic work Mike bet
encouraged joined us from Columbia to
help out yeah so this is about embedding
optimization problems in continuous time
and once you've done that you learn
about why algorithms would behave
certain ways in discrete time okay
there's gonna be phase transitions
happen only in continuous time that you
would never have seen just in discrete
time or with great labor
okay so let me say something a little
bit kind of grandiose sounding but if
you look at the fields that are
mathematically the most mature they make
serious usage of the fundamental theorem
of calculus there are some differentials
and there's also some integrals all
right and fields that aren't so Matt and
I would surely picked one or the other
all right so physics is the poster child
for this you know Newton wrote down F
equals MA which is laws of nature using
derivatives it's a differential equation
and then logroño years later and said I
could rewrite all that physics using
integrals I'm gonna integrate an energy
and then moreover he introduced
optimization I'm going to optimize the
integral of the energy and I will get
out the same physics probability theory
it's full of this Tala grands uh you
know smart paths are this Fineman
diagrams or this statistics has you know
the Laplace expansions and Southpoint
expansions so anyways all this is really
just fun with Herman calculus used in
elaborated ways the numerical
disciplines also finite element Alice's
you take a PDE and you just create
little patches using integrals and
relate those integrals to each other
Monte Carlo is trying to do integration
by using derivatives inside of the
integral and so on so you can now ask
about optimization is it one of these
mutual fields as I alluded to earlier it
was kind of thought of as done you know
all right so it's not done and in
particular it's only focused on
differentiation you open up paper after
paper and there's all these derivatives
and there's insanity there's an equality
is based on the derivatives but there's
almost never an integral sign it's just
some Taylor expansion of something
you're ignoring but otherwise it's not
really fundamentally part of the field
so I would argue the field is not mature
yet okay so let's now again fix ideas by
looking at a simple situation let's talk
about convex optimization again smooth
convex optimization here's variance int
again and now here's a new fact that if
your throat issue you know what
otherwise you might not is that not only
does this algorithm have a specific
convergence rate for a particular
function over the entire class of convex
functions it has a convergence rate and
that rate is here so this is a worst
case rate it says that after K steps
have gone by you are within 1 over K
order 1 over K of the optimum okay so
that's a convergence rate for the trial
so it's a complexity result really ok so
once that was known and probably been a
few decades now the russian school
arkady nemirovsky predictor asks a
variance to question they said is there
a general complexity result here is
there a lower bound for this class of
algorithms now what does that mean well
first of all the he had to think about
what kind of computer am I talking about
to get a lower bound so we're gonna look
at all possible algorithms I have to
talk about the platform and if you
talked about touring complexity at this
point that wouldn't be very helpful the
lower bound beats or a zero
just look at the description of the
function and figure out the answer all
right so it had to be a more restricted
to family and so he said well I just got
allow you to look at the gradient and
I'm gonna allow you to keep all previous
gradients and your your updates must be
in the span of all the linear span of
all previous gradients so it's a very
powerful machine but it's not touring
complete but you can make progress with
it all right and so the after doing that
he said in this family for smooth convex
functions what's the best you can do and
he proved that it was 1 over K squared
it was faster than grainy descent so and
so there was an open period of time
where no one knew whether it was an
algorithm that could be trained to send
it arrived at that lower bound so it was
something of a surprise when you're a
nester of in 1983 wrote down this
algorithm which has got two pieces
instead of just one and it achieves the
lower bound of 1 over K squared and so
it's a kind of some amazing facts about
it well first of all it is kind of
grating a sad thing that y-variable
there's two variables now why is usually
the X gradient and then the new ax is
kind of a linear combination of the
previous two Y so it's got this heavy
ball or momentum flavor there's like a
little bit of implicit here but it's a
bit of a mystery it where's where this
comes from but it's no mystery that it
does achieve this rate okay that's
really amazing moreover one of the
mysteries is that this thing is not a
descent algorithm it can go down and
then go back up and go back down again
that seems strange for you're trying to
get down to the bottom as fast as
possible and we need a said is the
steepest descent so how can you beat it
but you really are beating it alright so
again I think it's you got to go into
continuous time to understand this so
let's start with going into canoe song
which is gradient descent so here's the
gradient flow widely studied by the
mathematician still to this day and you
can analyze the rate of convergence of
that for convex functions and the rate
is 1 over T ok corresponds the 1 over K
for grading descent alright so now you
can ask what if I take the Nesterov
equation which has a 1 over K squared
and I look at the I take the step size
to 0 and get out a differential equation
you will get out 1 here's what gets you
get out this was done by sue boyd and
Kandace and you can analyze the rate of
this and it is 1 over T squared
okay it's interesting equation it's the
second order no surprise because you had
two equations there's a mysterious three
here and there's a damping term and
there it is that is the differential
equation for Nesterov alright so we
looked at this and said that's an
interesting difference of equation but
where does that come from why is that
the best differential equation and what
since why is it giving you the optimal
result okay so it's a little bit like
looking at F equals MA and saying that's
a great differential equation but why
that differential equation where's it
coming from is their energy principle
allows us to derive that differential
equation from some principle okay so
that's what we worked on and we have a
paper about a year and a half ago and
PNAS I'm just gonna show you the answer
these are answer our answer was to write
down the following lagrangian so it's in
continuous-time the alphas betas and
gammas are not the important part
they're just degrees of freedom they
give you a family of algorithms on just
one algorithm all right we'll set them
in particular ways so that's just time
scalenes the important part is this
thing right here which is called a
Bregman divergence hopefully most of you
know what that is there's the math of a
regular version here's the picture
you're trying to measure distance
between x and y you do that by writing
out an auxiliary function H and you take
the linear approximation of H at X and
you look at the discrepancy at Y so that
red amount there is the Burgman
divergence it measures the distance on
the x axis by using this vertical
distance if H is quadratic this just
becomes Euclidean distance in X and y
this is just a variational way of
writing out Euclidean distance but age
could be logarithmic and and all sorts
of other things are possible all right
and so we're gonna use the Pegman
divergence in a novel way we're gonna
measure regular divergence between X
where we are now and X plus a time
scaled X dot so it's kind of a little
bit of I got elasticity if you will or
energy along the direction of the flow
so think in fact if this is like a
kinetic energy and then we take a time
scale version the function we're going
downhill on that's like a potential we
want to go down on that this is like a
kinetic minus a potential a Lagrangian
moreover if you set H to quadratic this
thing reduces to one-half X dot squared
so it literally becomes the classical
kinetic energy and this is literally
Lagrangian it's a time variant
lagrangian's we want to not just
oscillate around we want to write but we
want to end up at the optimum okay so
what do you do with lagrangian's well
you put them inside of an integral and
you optimize over paths all right and
that's what we do here so we put it
inside of an integral and we optimize
over paths so now compute some path and
we'll compute a dynamics along that path
all right and the way you get all that
is it by a differential equation and how
do you get that different equation well
you you set all the partial is equal to
0 essentially the continuous time
version of that that's called the Euler
Lagrange equation so I just hit that
object with some derivatives and I will
pop a differential equation and I will
do it this is our master differential
equation here it is this I claim this
describes a vast family of accelerated
methods in continuous-time it has an X
double dot it's got a damping term and
it's got a bunch of geometry right here
if you set H to 2 quadratic and if you
set alpha and beta as logarithmic in T
then this whole thing reduces to that su
Boyd in Canada's differential equation
with a 3 over T and all that but this
also gives you a whole bunch of others
mirror descents acceleration cubic
progress Newton acceleration and a whole
bunch of others so in some sense it is
capturing this family
in continuous time all right next
question does it give you anything more
all right this is it for example give
you convergence rate okay because
usually convergence rates are a
case-by-case basis that's a couple of
pages of you know Koshi schwartz indians
and inequality and so on
and so it's a pleasant surprise and I
think it's helped us feel that we were
on the right path with this line of work
that there's a one-line proof of
convergence the convergence rate is Big
O of e to the minus beta T where beta T
is a degree of freedom you get a set ok
talk about that in a minute
and the proof is just you write down a
Lyapunov function again using the
Bregman divergence you take its first
time derivative and your asset that be
negative that happens if and only if
this is true so there's how are your
convergence rate once and for all ok
and again asia has worked a lot only
operative function she is
she's not only worked with this one but
also done the mapping between the
screamin continuous-time layout that are
functions kind of getting rid of the
Nesterov estimating sequenced techniques
if you will replacing them okay now
what's this point start to become
interesting because this suggests that
you can achieve any rate you want to
achieve
I said beta of T was a degree of freedom
okay so suppose that I know a little bit
about convex optimization I know I don't
expect to get a neck special rate that
seems not plausible okay so I'm gonna be
not ambitious I'm gonna set beta of T to
say logarithm of T and then the
logarithm and kills the X pension I get
1 over T I know the gradient flow
achieves that alright so let's see if I
would recover great and flow well I just
take that definition of beta I plug it
back into the Euler Lagrangian or my
different my master differential
equation and I saw that I get gradient
flow okay now Eric comes along he says I
want to I can go faster I'm gonna set
beta T to to long T so I get 1 over T
squared he puts that in the owner garage
equation it delivers that Nesterov
accelerated method okay no derivation
just the math does it all right she says
no I can want to go faster I want T cute
so he puts in 3 log T and he actually
gets out of differential converges the
rate 1 over T cubed okay and G 1 comes
alone says no I'm gonna do it
exponentially look the math permits it
so I'm gonna do it so I'm gonna set beta
T's just equal to T he will do that he
will get her L'Orange equation and he
will get a differential equation and in
continuous time he will flow along at
that rate no problem ok now here's
what's interesting all four of us will
go along exactly the same path right
it's just that one of us will go slowly
on that path one will go faster and he
will zip right along
all right so in continuous-time
acceleration is not it's not the rate
that's interesting it's the path it's
about this particular geometry of this
path the global geometry okay it's the
path why is that happening well because
this Lagrangian is covariant has a
differential geometry operator that's
why okay now so this actual speed we go
just means we're using different clocks
okay and who cares all right just you
know he's a slow clock I guess a fast
pocket so he's a super fast clock
so it's like Einstein says the clock
actually doesn't matter it's not
interesting here okay what is it it's a
path now but here's where it finally
gets really interesting which is that
Eric and me and she are going to these
rates we know that we can achieve ours
she Jenna's being a little more
ambitious but he can actually achieve
one over T cube that's a discovery here
and he can't in the sense of going back
taking discrete time he can't put this
on a computer ok so what's gonna happen
is that somehow his a differential
equation cannot be discretized stabili
okay so that's now a mystery at least a
year ago was a mystery why can't we
discretize the dynamics when we're using
these fast clocks or overly fast clocks
but we know we can't because if you
discretize it he'd meet the auricle rate
can't do that right what happens we
arrive at a clocks people we can
discretize and then how do we describe
once it's possible alright so I have
some theorems on this they're not
completely done in the sense I'd like
necessary to the fishing editions these
are mostly sufficient all right but they
all are coming out of the perspective
known as symplectic integration or
symplectic geometry how many of you know
about that already yeah one I hope you
know how many of you know what the FFT
is yeah so it's amazing somebody gives
you way more important than the FFT yeah
so it did so I'm gonna say a little bit
of what it is I think I have a slide on
yes here it is so this is a very
important area in mathematics
departments are have some plankton
geometries in them every mathematic
department has it has some of them it
came from the late 1800s when people
like hamilton-jacobi and Planck her eyes
some of those luminaries we're asking
the very instant they said we've got a
whole bunch of differential equations
lying around from from physics like
Maxwell's equations Newton's equations
fluid flow and so on we know that they
have some not just they're not just
differences they have some laws that if
I flow along the exact flow I could
serve like energy or momentum or volumes
and phase base all right now this is
before computers where they were asking
the following question what if we have
to discretize this to get an actual
algorithm we're now gonna hop along the
flow and not quite along the flow will
be a little bit off right but is there a
way to do that approximately such that
you exactly still conserve the laws of
physics you could serve the moment
the energy and all add you dude this
approximate path alright that's amazing
point that they asked this question and
they answered it and so this area of
simplex iteration does this and so I've
spent a year reading about this and
here's the basic short version of this
that normally you think of a vector
field a difference equation of the
vector field I'm moving along I'm at a
point I have a vector is leaving that
point I follow that vector a little bit
then I go to the next vector and I
stitch this long symplectic in Rachel's
a different perspective it says that at
any given point there's a triple of
vectors and that finds in a little
volume element and as I move along the
flow that volume out will shear but I
want the actual volume to stay constant
can I do that
well the volumes it'll determine it's an
alternating form so I have now
alternating forms on a manifold and
blank already worked on that right and
it turns out you can do it you can
exactly conserve these little volume
elements and the integrators that do
this are not Runge Katta or oil or
whatever they are a mixture of implicit
and explicit so there's implicit Runge
Katta explicit if you do one or the
other you're not symplectic but if you
mix them in a particular way you're
symplectic alright meaning that you can
serve these quantities right now this
seems pretty far away from acceleration
and certainly very far away from AI but
but it's not so when you conserve these
quantities an additional benefit is that
a bunch of higher-order terms vanish
because the symmetries are being
conservative that means you can move
much faster you can take much bigger
step size and that's the connection to
acceleration okay you take much faster
step size even optimal size steps all
right so so long story short with you
now there's a mathematical recipe that
starts from an optimization problem it
writes down the bregman lagrangian now
we're gonna go into the Hamiltonian
formalism it's just an easier way to
develop symplectic integrators
so the standard physics recipe you take
a look around you do Legendre transform
conjugate duality
goes over to Hamiltonian this
Hamiltonian is time varying we want to
get a time invariant one because that's
the easiest way to develop some like big
integrators so we do a standard
procedure called lifting we introduce a
time variable and its conjugate dual put
them in his explicit state variables now
we're in a space in which the
Hamiltonian is time invariant and
just run and symplectic integrator on
that off the shelf people in real
physics that simulate the cosmos or
proteins were ever only used symplectic
ignorance they do not use anything else
so there's a standard software and
standard methodology for doing this okay
so let me show you a picture of doing
this this is just a particular high
dimensional optimization problem
particular function we didn't have to
think at all
we simply plugged in the function or
garag equation hamiltonian selecting and
put it on a computer and you see it
converges it is awesome lady it goes up
and down as predicted and we are
achieving an Oracle wait okay if I I
don't I didn't want spend much more time
on this but if I put Nesterov next to
this Nesterov roughly is the same it has
a phase near the end which it goes a
little faster which I could talk more
about if you're interested but now if
you turn up the step size nestdrop goes
unstable and this thing's a stable down
to a factor of about 10 we can get a 10
wall clock improvement with this
algorithm okay now I'm going to go back
to work with qi again now that we have
so many ingredients we can put these
together yeah please yeah so you do
what's called splitting you take this a
big old hamiltonian split it into pieces
and you make sure the implicit part is
easy to is easy to do and now typically
this is what's called the leapfrog
integrator or the implicit part is
actually not so not so complicated but
in absolute you split wrong you could
have the implicit part be real load okay
but it's part of future researchers kind
of characterized cases where that's not
the problem
okay so trying to I'm gonna try to
finish up here in a couple minutes
sliding into the optimum here so an open
promise then the acceleration helped you
get past a low points mention that
before and taking this continuous time
perspective this Hamiltonian perspective
if you will helps feel to answer this
question okay so I mean it's kind of
skip a little bit these are some slides
I actually borrowed from Qi here let me
just skip over this okay we're gonna be
interested in this set e that we've
talked about already its smoothness for
gradient smoothness for Hessian and we
want to bring in acceleration now and
hit second-order stationary points so
it's setup is the same as before and
here is an algorithm
you can analyze it basically just I
don't wanna get any details it's
gradient ascent it's this perturbation
as well and it also is an accelerated
dog refer okay accelerates and perturbs
and here is a theorem which says that
the rate now goes down from epsilon
squared epsilon to the seventh fourth so
proof that yet that just pure
acceleration does help you to get past
saddle points the ODE tilde again is a
poly logarithmic term in dimension so
that didn't go away here is the
Hamiltonian that was used in this
particular paper it's actually a simpler
version of alto nyan and I won't get any
details but that was key and getting the
theorem here and then last two slides
now let's start this is ongoing work is
trying to bring this into the world of
Markov chain Monte Carlo and try to
contribute there so to do that we're
gonna study her father's work with Zhang
Jiang and and Peter Bartlett and Gilad
reach RG Berkeley we're gonna try to
accelerate now not just gradient flow or
gradient descent we're gonna try to
accelerate diffusion stochastic
processes that sample like Markov chain
Monte Carlo does there have been
negative results on this she because its
diffusion it's got a lot of noise its
Brownian motion and trying to accelerate
Briony motion is not so easy but those
results have been on what's called over
damped longer than in the physics
literature over damn diffusions this is
just that you take the gradient and you
add Brownian motion it's like waiting to
sin but wasn't not just pure so Cassidy
it adds Brownian motion directly to the
grave yet alright so we've just seen
that these momentum kind of methods are
able to go faster all right so what if
we go to a more momentum version of
launch event alright so here it is this
is classical all japan this is
stochastic differential equation
notation it just takes the gradient goes
down in ads Brownian motion all right
we're gonna look at an under damped
launch of n or you add Brownian motion
to the velocity and then you integrate
the velocity so the noise incurred the
bad noise is occurred by the Brownian
motions getting filtered
okay and here is my last slide so there
has been beautiful work in France on
analyzing finally kind of finite time
convergence results for long Japan it
goes
over epsilon squared and for
under-damped our paper shows that it you
you go all the way down from epsilon 2
epsilon squared epsilon okay and again
and this the proof here needs this
continuous time Hamiltonian perspective
to to go okay I wanted to skip that yeah
so I'm basically done I did want to give
up one of my two minors just wanted a
bit of publicity for this project called
Ray we have a you know on my list of
other topics to work on is a large long
list of things that are kind of
engineering our systems computer system
stuff and so part of my career the last
10 years has been investing and having
labs with computer scientists who are
assistants people not AI people
including people like John Stoica and
Dave Patterson and so on and we've had
several labs now the amp lab the rise
lab with the rad lab that have been real
success stories and I would give a
separate talk on that
just let me note that spark came out of
this lab kind of the interaction gene
machine learning people and systems
people and we have a new project called
ray which is kind of spark for
reinforcement learning spark is a block
synchronous paradigm where you parallel
eyes and each parallel thread or process
has got to kind of roughly run the same
amount of time if you do rollouts and
reinforcement learning or so classic
search some rollouts take a long time to
decide it was a bad idea and others take
very short time to decide it was a bad
idea
and so you have this heterogeneous
workloads and Ray attempts to or does
accommodate that so here's the author
list philip morris and robert Ishihara
students working with me at berkeley and
then yonce toika and let me just cut I
want to just say this exists and I'm not
going to show that's there I want to
show it is an open source project and it
has now some kind of beers throughout
the world and you can put it on your
laptop within five minutes and not be up
and running it and so I'd like to
encourage people here or systems minded
to have a look at what we're doing right
that's pretty interesting so that's all
I could pop up to the top level but I
think I've said everything I want to say
and I usually asking about raise it
smartcash know that was sparked no that
was the Rae is basically about smart
scheduling you got to decide once a
little threat you know process is kind
of really quickly so you're doing like
game search you know do alphago and
you're going down a game tree and you
realize pretty quickly I was a stupid
idea
and so the processor should be liberated
to do something else so you have a
dynamic flow graph you're an actor
paradigm and you decide intelligently
which new processor to give another
which processor do you have another job
and then you have a global and local
schedulers interacting in a fairly
complex way so there's a big dance of
scheduling going on there's objects
store and scheduling issues behind the
hood okay
beyond my first question to get these
moving questions yes I can repeat the
question so in the nester formylation I
didn't see any structure or geometry
about the loss function so does it apply
to all objective functions or some does
it nothing applies to all objective
functions so yeah there are some
constraints on the objective function
there I mean that was that result which
is for convex the Nesterov yeah even
comments but you know there's mirror
descent allows you to get a lot of
geometry into there you know the mirror
descent version there's there's the same
theory applies to mirror descent but
going beyond that to other kinds of non
convex and other kind of loss functions
you have to do some problem specific
work on that which is that's gonna be
life that's why we'll always be employed
you have to think about your loss
function and you have to think about the
properties of the loss function and you
have to exploit the structure of that
and so on and so forth are generic
feelings will guide you but they're not
gonna just you know that's not gonna be
plug-and-play for quite some time
Kris Meeke back in the bank yeah no no
this is just uh it's just a way of
forming what we mean by a rate of
convergence
yeah epsilon you want to try to say it
more cleanly than I can this is Martha
you know meta-level observation in the
sense that you know a bunch of
techniques that you mentioned who in the
continuous time space and we have to
discretize it because of our computer
architectures yeah so do you think there
is enough motivation for few of us to
start looking at you know computing in
the continual log yeah I've been asked
that question before I actually believe
it yes I mean I like the symplectic
approach because it's a beautiful way to
discretize but there are some real
advantages to working just purely
continuous time don't have to worry
about some of these issues or stability
you know issues that are handled for you
so yeah this is the first time I've
worked on something where I feel like
yeah actually I would like to have a lot
of uh computer to do this I think would
be really interesting to explore you're
also thinking about more generalizations
like variational equilibria and yeah oh
I thought about that and even try to
work on that kinda thing from time to
time I am aware for example of an
interesting literature of not escaping
saddle points but going towards a low
points right and they're still actually
open problems there of how fast can you
approach a saddle point cuz the south
playing young game theoretic optimum is
what you want to be at not a void
and so yeah it just like the next 10
years of my career I guarantee there'll
be a fair amount of more economic stuff
in it I already have some ideas and but
I you know that's what I tend to do in
life as I say what I'm gonna do and then
I just try to work on it and help up
where other people will teach me things
along the way because I didn't I know
very little about serious economics math
I just hope I can learn it quickly I
they work with statistics and
differential equations so I should be
ready to go but yeah I know the MSR has
got a lot of people here and I think
that this is kind of a you know I think
of a bob he'll wear this but it's not
just about advertised placement that's
not a big application of more of you
know economics and machinery together to
me it is actually the trillion dollar
play at how do you actually really use
this load balancing problem I alluded to
it's critical and machine learning
people aren't thinking about it at all
they're thinking you're gonna deploy
things and you know they're not thinking
about that you know either for scarcity
out there it's not gonna work in there
in a domain narrow domain like
transportation you know yes they'll do
dynamic programming lots and everybody
down the same route but that's it's it's
a way broader problem and that's you
know using it really in in bidding
mechanism or economics there and my
answer always was people use Bing Maps
to make this to make this a big deal
[Laughter]
so I have one funny anecdote since
you're telling good funny anecdotes I
wanted to try to top you which wasn't
China now and I was giving this talk
about AI and everyone's asking me you
know although is although I brought you
know hey I Troodon
try to tamp it down but they were
pushing on well you know yeah all your
problems maybe it's could take decades
but you know in pure human imitative AI
were made such progress like they could
think about natural language translation
it's nearly solved isn't it and and so
you know Doug Hoff said I wrote a very
nice article if you haven't seen this
chalice of Google Translate that if you
haven't read that you should read that
everybody aware that just getting to 90
or 95% does not mean we're within 5% of
the answer we're way away from you know
give you good examples right but anyway
on the screen behind me there was a
panel session but one the speakers
didn't make it then was on the screen
virtually behind us I will name this
person this person was going on about
you know AI and translation and
autonomous this and that and how
translation we were not quite there yet
but you know Italy within 10 years we'll
definitely done it and there was an
automatic translation going on the
screen I think it was so go I think it
was the Chinese thing and it was
transcription and translation so the
speaker said at some point that's a red
herring for in that's a red herring in
AI okay everyone know what a red herring
is okay a red herring is a as a fish a
herring is a kind of fish and red
herring someone probably knows the
etymology better than me just means
something that everyone's paying
attention you shouldn't pay attention
well event that's a red herring don't
worry about it so he says some something
I forget the topic is a red herring in
AI and the translation came up was
that's a red hair in his eye that's not
the monkey part that's that's new
element quite a monkey needed in this
[Laughter]